is
oh my goodness amanda you look
absolutely gorgeous who's the designer
of your down the side i wouldn't be away
this evening oh honey you are looking
like a vision thank you so much so first
met gala
first time around
as a co-chair yes how are you feeling
going into this evening i'm feeling
incredible i'm really fortunate that my
first met gala is also one that i'm
co-chairing yeah so i feel like i'm
getting the very best welcome to the
gala into the night so i'm just ready
for it i mean who are you most looking
forward to meeting this year or this
evening because you have had quite a
year yes you know what i'm really
looking forward to meeting my co-chairs
i'm looking forward to meeting naomi
timothy billy even sitting down with
anna winter we haven't been able to come
together in this way
and what is this here oh okay so this is
a book that says give us your tired
tonight i am a reimagined statue of
liberty and at the base of the statue
there's a poem about immigrants so i
decided to come and represent poetry
tonight you are such a beautiful young
thank you congratulations thank you so
much